An EPA source says the
agency has not fully accepted
Norfolk Southern's
remediation plan
regarding the toxic train
derailment in eastern Ohio.
This as residents and farmers living near
the derailment
site are waiting for answers
as to
whether their health is in jeopardy.
Here's CNN's Miguel Marquez.
Come on, girls.
Come on, girls. Come on, girls.
Dave Anderson raises grass fed
beef four miles
downwind of East Palestine, Ohio.
After the derailment, fire
and venting of toxic chemicals.
This is what drifted over
his Echo Valley farm.
As far as the smoke,
you could probably see 100 yards.
You know, it was dark
and what did you experience?
Burning eyes,
burning throat, burning mouth.
The cloud from the toxic
spill settled on his pastures and ponds.
The question
he now cannot answer
are the cattle he's raised for years.
Okay for human consumption.
Customers are buying grass fed
beef directly from a farmer
They care about their food.
They want to know what they're getting.
They want to know what top notch
and healthy for them.
He's now sued Norfolk Southern.
He also wants testing a process,
a way to certify his livestock is safe.
The lawsuit is about peace of mind
to start with. Right.
And information and make decisions
Solid information here. Tough to come by.
Officials have established
a two mile zone around the derailment
site as a priority
because Anderson's farm
is farther away,
despite being directly
in the path of the plume
from the toxic spill.
He's yet received little support
and no answers
from Pennsylvania's
Department
of Environmental Protection DEP.
What will assuage your concerns?
Testing. But there has been no testing.
None.
None so deep
he's not been out here at all.
If he came yesterday
for the first time, four weeks
after the event,
a little more than four weeks after,
they've they test, they take samples.
They did not.
They were investigating
whether they should
be active in this area outside of the two
mile ring.
The crash occurred
just feet from the Pennsylvania border.
The winds typically
blow east toward Pennsylvania.
The state is going house
to house,
testing soil
and water in areas
closest to the derailment.
What did you see that night?
Standing at
the end of the driveway, I saw
a huge plume of smoke.
I saw flames above the treetops,
well over 100 feet in the air
and it was terrifying.
Samuel Wenger
and his wife, Joyce,
had their fourth
child, Jaxson Hayes, a week ago.
He says the state's response
has been too slow
and lacking in information
to know
whether his town
of Darlington, Pennsylvania,
is still a safe place to raise a family.
Have you tested your well
or has it been tested?
It was tested today
and we were told
will be another three weeks
until we get results.
Wenger who works in landscaping,
says they evacuated for four days,
but moving permanently isn't an option.
How tough
was it to come back to this house
knowing that you bring a newborn here?
I feel like I
possibly regret the decision every day,
but here we live paycheck to paycheck.
We live within our means and
we don't have the financial luxury
to pack up and move.
We just it's scary.
The CDC is now conducting a health survey
in and around
East Palestine,
trying to determine the long
term effects on human health.
While air
and water testing is occurring,
daily answers about long term health
won't come quickly.
We are hoping in the next couple of weeks
to be able to have collected
all of the information that we need
and then those results
will be available in the coming months.
For Pennsylvania residents
and business owners
downwind of the toxic fire Answers
can't come soon enough.
But you're losing business
because people aren't sure
it's safe to eat your food.
Yeah, I think so.
I lost the wedding over that
catering job.
They just they don't know.
I mean,
I don't think there's
anything wrong with anything,
but I don't know either.
It must hurt.
Yeah, it sucks.
I'm sorry.
I don't know how else to put it.
It's just the uncertainty.
Pennsylvania officials have pushed back
pretty hard on the notion
that not enough
is being done in this area.
They say they've tested
nearly every well
within a two mile
radius of the derailment,
and those results will be in soon.
They have a plan to sample soil
throughout the area as well.
They've worked with animal experts
and animal welfare experts to inform
farmers of the best practices
for the situation.
They say they've also opened up
a health clinic with hundreds of people
have already taken advantage of
and can continue to take advantage of it.
They also say that all the information
all the testing,
all the public information about best
practices is all available,
both online and in-person.
Brianna.